David Tennant obviously you're part of
the yeah the you've ever seen Doctor Who
my son lived here a year and a half and
he turned me on to the show and it's
it's amazing I love it
although I think Bill and Ted ripped you
guys off Pete it's yeah that's all right
that's a good reference and is this the
Doctor Who you saw yes okay she says
with confidence only one that's right
Doctor Who it continues you see because
they keep regenerating yes yeah if you
tuned in now James Bond
yeah there's a different one yeah gonna
be girls now it is it is a woman now and
obviously because it's so top secret
who's gonna be the new yeah but because
you had worked so closely with Jodie on
yeah on broadchurch
yeah did you know did she confide in you
I knew a little bit before but only
because because Chris Chibnall who wrote
broadchurch who we both know is no
runnin Doctor Who so he phoned me up and
said I'm the next doctor would like to
call you
is that okay no no don't worry don't
worry they'll be the next person to call
it was very high level
so we're open
I sort of put my phone down and waited
for it to ring and of course because I
know Jordy her name pops up and it was
very exciting
Wow and oddly you met your wife on the
cess of the review yeah but she is the
daughter of a doctor who yes which must
drive Doctor Who people into a frenzy I
mean it is statistically quite unlikely
but it oh there we all are
look there's a three of us yeah
embarrassing I'm winning the same suit
[Laughter]
[Applause]
doesn't make me leave very what he swept
in celebrity toxic
it's a very nice one you were going to
just wear a one strike you know you know
it works you know it works
nothing
[Music]
you